[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis à très heureux de
vous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 78 évidemment dédié ce
mois ci à la crise du coronavirus nous
verrons notamment durant cette émission
comment la région ile de france utilise
les fonds structurels européens dont
elle est responsable pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire et économique
l'utilisation de ces fonds destinés
d'ordinaire à financer des projets de
réinsertion et des dalles emploi et
notamment assouplies pour venir en aide
aux secteurs les plus impactés stéphanie
von euw le vice président de la région
ile de france en charge des affaires
européennes répondra à distance à nos
questions
confiné ils poursuivent leur travail
depuis chez eux
françois-xavier belle amie mathilde
andraud et mounir satouri eurodéputés
yvelinois nous donneront leur avis sur
la gestion de la crise par l'union
européenne les institutions du vieux
continent qui ont annoncé à différents
plans de relance et de soutien de
plusieurs centaines de milliards d'euros
et qui doivent néanmoins composer avec
des états beaucoup moins enclins à la
solidarité
enfin nous verrons que c'est toute
l'europe qui est confiné si les mesures
ne sont pas les mêmes partout sur le
continent le résultat est sensiblement
le même les citoyens sont invités à
rester chez eux
vous entendrez les témoignages dit vinoy
confiné à l'étranger
on
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire qui bouleverse donc
la vie des européens depuis un mois
désormais confiné au ralenti
économiquement l'europe cherche à
limiter les dégâts sur son économie a
aidé aussi les secteurs les plus
impactés comme la santé parmi les
propositions des institutions il y a
notamment la possibilité de réorienter
les fonds européens pour faire face à la
crise les fonds structurels européens
qui sont gérés vous le savez par la
région ile de france stéphanie von euw 9
bonjour vous êtes avec nous par
téléphone vous êtes la vice présidente
de la région ile de france en charge des
affaires européennes justement
expliquez-nous dans quelle mesure
justement ces fonds structurels
européens peuvent permettre aujourd'hui
de lutter financièrement contre la crise
du coc vide 19
c'est une aide financière complémentaire
qui vient qui va permettre de déployer
démultiplier les moyens mis notamment
alors il ya 2 2 temps de mesure il ya le
premier c'est les mesures immédiates et
les mesures d'urgence et notamment
l'application fort de la région
ile-de-france pour acheter de très
nombreux masques de ski à près de 30
millions de masques qui ont été achetés
et pour acheter ces 30 millions de
masques par la région ile de france ce
sont 10 millions d'euros de fonds
européens qui sont venus s'additionner à
dix millions dix millions d'euros de
fonds propres de la région ile de france
est un exemple très très contre l
utilisation des fonds européens deuxième
exemple c'est que à travers les fonds
européens on abonde le fond de la baie
pays qui est la banque publique
d'investissement pour permettre de faire
des prêts à taux zéro pour les
entreprises et donc là c'est 23 millions
d'euros qui a été mobilisé pour ce fonds
avec la bpi qui au total permettront de
libérer plus de 85 millions d'euros pour
les entreprises
et puis enfin on a bon dos on abonde le
qu'on appelle le pacte de relocalisation
ou là c'est ça sera des mesures plus
deux reprises un de plan de relance à
l'issue à l'issue de la deûle à de cette
crise pour inciter ou pour aider et
accompagner les entreprises qui
souhaiteraient se relocaliser en région
la 10 millions d'euros encore qui sont
ou qui sont mobilisés plus globalement
on est on est enfin de programmation et
en fin d'utilisation de l' enveloppe
budgétaire de fonds de fonds européens
il nous reste à ce stade 50 millions
d'euros à programmer ses 50 millions
d'euros à programmer vont être
intégralement fléchi sur les mesures
d'urgence où les mesures de sortie de
crise
concrètement si si je vous comprends
bien l'union européenne et plus
précisément la commission la commission
européenne vous facilite aujourd'hui la
vis et c'est ça l'objectif
on sait que les fonds européens ne
peuvent financer qu'une partie des
projets habituellement aujourd'hui tout
ça est assouplie c'est effectivement une
réalité donc là la commission européenne
a pris la mesure de la nécessité absolue
de simplifier l'utilisation des fonds
européens dont vous avez raison de
rappeler que normalement les fonds
européens ne sont utilisés que dans
cofinancement là aujourd'hui nous
pouvons effectivement utilisé 100 % de
fonds européens
105 kg et d'apports extérieurs ça c'est
le saas et le premier point le deuxième
point on a pu faciliter les ce qu'on
appelle les maquettes c'est à dire le
plan opérationnel le programme
opérationnel pour basculer du fonds
social européen vert du feder c'est à
dire du fonctionnement vers
l'investissement ce qui était interdit
c'est désormais c'est désormais
autorisés donc tout ça pour nous
faciliter la réorientation sur sur les
mesures d'urgence
un point sur lequel nous restons
extrêmement vigilants et là dessus
l'association régions de france qui
regroupe toutes les régions de france et
qui fait un gros gros travail de
lobbying auprès des institutions
européennes
ce travail est encore en cours parce que
ce que nous redoutons etc ou alors ce
dont nous voulons vraiment nous assurer
c'est que au moment des audits puisque
la commission européenne fait contrôler
systématiquement l'utilisation des fonds
au moment des audits c'est à dire dans
deux ans les auditeurs n'oublie pas que
sur ces fonds là sur cette programmation
nous étions sur des règles dites
particulière compte tenu de la crise
sanitaire de manière à ce que nous
n'ayons pas ensuite d'aidé
sanction voir des pans entiers de la
programmation qu'ils soient qui soigne
une et ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et régions
france fait un travail formidable de ce
point de vue là qu'en est il pour autant
des projets qui recevait déjà des
financements européens et des projets
qui étaient en cours pour les
collectivités associations est ce que
leur financement
sont-ils tout de même assuré là on peut
être extrêmement rare qu elle qui avait
déjà été programmées vont aller à leur
terme
je vais même aller peut-être plus loin
toutes les équipes de la direction des
affaires européennes sont en télétravail
mais que du coup il ya un gros travail
de fond d'instruction d'instruction des
dossiers qui est en train d'être faits
qui était un travail qui sur lequel il y
avait du retard
compte tenu d'un certain nombre de
réunions et d'audit qui était qui
étaient en cours dans la mesure où ces
audits sont un peu suspendue ou en tout
cas le son à un rythme moins moins
important tout ce travail d'instruction
est en train d'être d'être rattrapé donc
oui les porteurs de projets peuvent être
rassurés ça ira jusqu'au bout et toute
la programmation aujourd'hui qui est
mobilisé sur et les fonds européens qui
sont mobilisés sur la lutte contre le
coup des 19
ce sont des crédits qu'ils n'étaient
encore jusqu'à présent pas encore
programmée c'est pour ça que je vous
parlais de ces femmes et 50 millions
d'euros
merci à stéphane yvan 9 pour toutes vos
réponses je rappelle que vous êtes vice
présidente de la région ile de france en
charge des affaires européennes et donc
des fonds structurels européens dont
nous parlons est très souvent dans cette
émission via des reportages sur ces
projets merci encore à vous le
coronavirus est évidemment aussi cet
aspect terrible et avec des chiffres
très impressionnants selon des données
arrêtées à la date de ce 10 avril et qui
concerne l'europe géographique et 38
pays il ya actuellement en europe
un peu plus de 450 mille cas détectés et
plus de soixante trois mille personnes
décédées ducobu de 19 et l'italie
l'espagne la france sont bien sûr les
pays les plus touchés
la grande bretagne compte elle près de
57 milles personnes positif au qu'ovide
19 en ce moment est un peu moins de
8000 décès à l'échelle communautaire à
présent les institutions européennes ont
dégainé je vous le disais des plans
massifs dépassant parfois plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros pour
aider les économies du continent les
états quand viennent de trouver un
accord portant sur 500 milliards d'euros
cette mobilisation qui est une première
par son ampleur ne cache pas néanmoins
certains manquements européen c'est ce
que pense en tout cas les eurodéputés
yvelinois ils sont trois à avoir été élu
il ya un an
leur réaction et leur regard porté sur
cette crise s'est mise en image par
jules grenier ville plus de mille
milliards d'euros de la banque centrale
européenne et des états qui s'accordent
finalement sur un soutien de 540
milliards d'euros
les et des financements accordés aux
entreprises et aux banques du continent
sont inédites
pourtant les critiques sont nombreuses
pour juger l'action de l'union
européenne pour mathilde andrew et
secrétaire départemental du
rassemblement national des yvelines élu
en mai dernier au parlement européen les
institutions communautaires se sont
réveillés bien trop tard pour aider les
pays les plus fragiles
l'europe est globalement a raté
complètement son entrée dans la crise
clairement il y avait une division des
peuples un abandon total notamment de
l'italie et ça a été très flagrant et
d'ailleurs je pense que les italiens
sont maintenant très remontés contre les
institutions européennes
là il était nécessaire pour leurs
propres sauvegardes ailleurs de mettre
de l'argent sur la table des reproches
et les républicains également
françois-xavier bellamy aussi un
conseiller municipal de versailles et
tête de liste de son parti il y a un an
estime lui que l'europe n'est toujours
pas prête à affronter une telle crise et
ce malgré son expérience
aujourd'hui c'est la vie solitaire hier
c'était la crise migratoire
demain ce sera peut-être un défi
sécurité aux militaires il faut qu'on
puisse se donner les moyens par exemple
d'avoir une vision stratégique claire
sur la question de la santé
mais ça doit être aussi le gâchis et sur
l'agriculture ça doit être aussi le lait
sur les questions de sécurité commune
que nous puissions garder à l'esprit que
ce qui compte ce n'est pas seulement le
marché européen à gauche enfin mounir
satouri anciens d'élu local aux mureaux
et eurodéputée écologiste
juge que c'est surtout le manque de
moyens mis à disposition de l'union qui
nuit à son action je pense profondément
quant à l'europe qu'on mérite la santé
la gestion des crises sanitaires n'est
pas une compétence européenne est en
fait on est toujours dans ce jeu de
reproches sur l'institution européenne
quand on est en difficulté et on a
raison de le faire
sauf qu'à aucun moment les états membres
les citoyens consomment on a fait le
choix que la santé était une compétence
communautaire
la problématique des compétences de
l'union européenne devrait agiter
bruxelles ces prochaines semaines crise
financière en 2008 de la dette en 2010
des migrants en 2015 est désormais
sanitaire en 2020 l'europe doit agir une
nouvelle fois dans l'urgence d'une
actualité sans répit peau elle est à
l'aune de cette crise et des critiques
qui ne cesse de pointer l'incohérence de
l'union européenne et son inaction une
question se pose quelles sont réellement
les capacités d'action de l'union
européenne justement n'est-elle pas être
tributaire du bon vouloir en fait des
états et des chefs d'état ont fait le
point avec trois questions pour vincent
couronne directeur de la publication les
surligneurs et enseignant à sciences po
saint germain en laye
l'union européenne ont fait est là une
compétentes qui met tous ses limites et
en réalité on quand on regarde les
traités européens
et puis on se rend compte de l'action de
lutte ni cours gérer justement qu'ils
endémiques comme témoin au rotavirus
elles ne permettent en fait que deux
cours d'eau et d'appuyer l'action des as
d'améliorer la coopération contre l'êta
aucunement de prendre la place des pas
pour agir et puis sur fable d'utiliser
l'armé budgétaire parce que cette arme
les terres du bureau d'al et très fin
l'union européenne et la présidente de
la commission européenne aussi
l'avant-dernier qui n'a reconnu à
peut-être mis un peu de temps à démarrer
parce que elle aurait pu beaucoup plus
tôt quand les premières informations qui
n'est rien arrivé de chine
commencez par on a lancé des programmes
l'achat de masques à transmettre des
recommandations
elle aurait pu commencer à travailler en
amont sur cette stèle n'a pas
véritablement auster en tout cas pas
complètement elle aucune tribu enseignes
européennes anticipé et un plusieurs
mois voire plusieurs années
en adoptant des des directives ou des
règlements européens qui permettait de
mieux faire face à ces crises épidémique
parce que ça c'est possible
elle peut le faire la une compétence
pour faire ça le problème c'est que dans
l'urgence ne marche pas parce que
anticiper ce genre de crise
ça réclame un vote au parlement européen
ensuite une approbation par le conseil
est donc ça c'est dire qu'ils prennent
des mois
c'est comme dans tout système de type
fédéral sans forcément dire que l'union
européenne est une étape verra
évidemment à mais dans un système de
type fédéral comme on voit par exemple
aux états unis la question des publics
relèvent essentiellement n'est pas au
niveau fédérer aux etats unis l'état de
new york s'était endormi etc qui gère
essentiellement des questions de santé
publique
et c'est pareil pour l'union européenne
c'est à dire que en cas de crise ce sont
les états qui gère ces questions de
santé publique et l'union européenne
elle elle peut agir mais uniquement pour
pouvoir les aider par exemple à
transférer des patients d'un état à
l'autre entre les hôpitaux les aider par
exemple à acheter en masse en grande
quantité des masques en lançant des
appels d'autres européens bon ça c'est
parce qu'elle l'a fait elle peut
également les aider par exemple aussi en
jouant sur la avec l'armée il ya
quelques jours l'union européenne à
supprimer l'intégralité des droits de
douane et de la tva et de tva sur tous
les produits
le matériel médical importés dans
l'union européenne
en réalité elle peut pas par exemple
imposer aux états le finement elle peut
pas non plus imposer la fermeture des
frontières
elle peut pas toutes choses comme ça
qu'elle ne peut pas faire si vous
regardez part dans le domaine trump aux
états unis il ne peut pas non plus la
fermeture des frontières entre l'état
américain
iris il avait fait se répéter contraire
à la situation américaine
ce que je trouve particulièrement
énervant irritant c'est d'entendre des
politiques qui critiquent union
européenne sait pas alors que ce sont
ces mêmes politiques
il ya des années mais depuis même
parfois les décennies refuse de se
retirer des complètement salut pour
qu'elle puisse être ce genre d'auto m et
je pense par exemple une peine récemment
a critiqué l
marine le pen qui elle même était face à
la très compétente et depuis le mois de
mars c'est l'ensemble du continent je
vous le disais qui est soumis à des
règles de confinement si certains pays
comme la suède et l'allemagne ont fait
le choix de mesures plus ou moins souple
d'autres comme la france l'italie ou la
belgique interdisent toute sortie hors
nécessité vitale
alors à quoi ressemble le confinement et
la vie de confiner ailleurs en europe et
coûté à ces témoignages d'yveline ouaki
aviv à l'étranger le temps de cette
période de très spécial
notre voyage européen nous amène en
pologne en allemagne et au pays de
galles bonjour à tous je m'appelle et me
cronje fait 22 ans et je suis originaire
de saint-germain-en-laye dans les
yvelines je suis actuellement en pologne
à cracovie où j'ai effectué mon service
de volontariat dans une école pour
jeunes en situation de handicap
et comme vous pouvez voir je suis dans
mon appartement je suis confirmé depuis
trois semaines maintenant voilà mesures
qui ont été prises par la pologne
donc c'est de façon préventive
la pologne qui a malheureusement pas été
épargné par le grenat virus on ne sent
pas chez nous depuis cet instant là et
donc forcément le service de volontariat
est quand même assez impact et munitions
étaient essentiellement en présentiel
donc j'allais à l'école du lundi au
vendredi et donc là forcément je ne peux
pas je ne peux pas y aller mais je reste
tout de même en contact avec mes élèves
avec les professeurs et les
coordinateurs de l'école parce qu'on a
un groupe facebook où on peut s'appeler
les professeurs envoie des exercices on
se soutient vouloir le moral tous
ensemble et c'est quand même important
voilà on peut faire je fais du sport du
yoga je regarde des films des séries je
veux sur mon ordinateur et je reste
beaucoup en contact avec ma famille
c'est important mais a mis les autres
volontaires présents a créé colis ce que
je dis souvent pour décrire mon gros
finement c'est que c'est un week end à
rallonge voilà c'est un week end très
prolongée je m'appelle nils j'ai 25 ans
je suis franco allemand est étudiant en
philosophie à l'université de bielefeld
en allemagne
l'allemagne est un état fédéral ce qui
veut dire que les laines la honte une
autonomie assez large en ce qui concerne
les mesures de lutte contre le coc vie
de 19 notamment la bavière et la sarre
qui ont choisi d'instaurer des mesures
de confinement presque aussi stricte
qu'en france donc ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas de coordination au
niveau national la plupart d'elana se
sont mis d'accord avec le gouvernement
allemand pour afin d'instaurer un
catalogue de mesures comment donc c'est
le cas de la rhénanie westphalie où je
me trouve actuellement
et donc il s'agit des mesures que l'on
retrouve dans la plupart des pays donc
fermeture de la majorité des commerces
fermeture des services d une institution
publique ce genre de choses
il ya une grande différence par rapport
à la france donc il s'agit de des
conditions de sortie
nous ne sommes pas obligés de remplir le
formulaire ou de de justifier notre
sortie de quelle manière que ce soit on
peut toujours sortir tout seul ou avec
les membres du foyer ou au maximum avec
une autre personne
issu d'un autre foyer dès que possible
les gens ont recours au télétravail dans
l'éducation autant dans les écoles que
dans les universités
tout ça ça se fait par par internet dès
que possible et pour ma part je suis
considéré concernés par les deux donc
d'un côté donc j'étudie à distance entre
guillemets et de l'autre côté j'ai aussi
un travail au sein du département de
philosophie et donc jeu dès que possible
je fais tout ça par internet
j'ai de la chance d'habiter très très
près du nom d'une forêt donc je profite
justement de ces mesures un peu moins
strictes pour me pour me promener en
forêt quand j'ai l'impression d'être un
peu enfermé chez moi
bonjour moi c'est évident mais j'ai vite
actuellement à peine y donc un village
situé à une heure de cardiff la capitale
du pays de galles
voici la carte du sud du pays de galles
avec cardiff la capitale qui se trouve
ici et notre village pour y trouve pas
ici les centres pour enfants bien
évidemment fermé et étendait que c'est
notre principale mission
on n'avait pas du tout de travail par
ordinateur et cetera par contre notre
connaîtra donc créé un groupe whatsapp
sur lesquels on peut voilà partager nos
idées un peu cherché ensemble qu'est ce
qu'on peut proposer aux jeunes via la
page facebook de l'association pendant
cette période
voilà on ça nous permet de rester en
contact et de partager nos idées on a de
la chance puisque notre cour arrière et
le parking d'un des centres ce qui fait
qu'on peut s'avérer et courir et faire
du sport à cet endroit là
[Applaudissements]
de nombreux messages positifs et un arc
en ciel sont apparus sur des vitres de
boutiques ou de maison qui prône smiling
d'ordinateurs a besoin pour ça le plus
chez nous a apporté des livres est un
puzzle de mes pièces
quentin à colloque autriche elle elle
s'occupe avec du nettoyage
grâce au confinement jaillissement les
temps de lire le livre sur notre action
va les chips qui date de 1977
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 europe
dédié à la crise du coronavirus j'espère
que cette émission vous aura permis de
mieux cerner les enjeux sanitaires mais
aussi économique que ce soit à l'échelle
de la région avec l'île de france aux
européennes avec nos différents
intervenants merci aussi à jules grandes
villes et romain russe fini pour le
montage et la réalisation de cette
émission on se retrouve très vite pour
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe dans des
conditions on l'espère bien différente a
très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le